SIERRA: So I saw this cartoon the other
day, and it showed two dinosaurs and they
were looking up at this giant meteor
and one yells to the other ‘Oh, no,
the economy’. And you know, it just makes
you think, do you think there's something
absurd about looking at this existential
problem from a financial standpoint?
MACKENZIE: Yeah, I absolutely do actually have a
lot of sympathy for that argument. Yeah, there's
a school of thought, which is that, you know,
talking about things in terms of the economy tends
to make people listen, who might not otherwise
want to listen or be inclined to listen. And,
a lot of people feel that it's safer to
talk about climate change in the context
of finance and the economy. Being in
the US people are very nervous about
straying into something that they think is
political or politicized. And that, in turn,
has created this kind of aversion to talking
about it in a really broad and robust way. And,
unfortunately, it's a simple rubric
for kind of analyzing and thinking
about climate change. It does make it kind of
easier for people to get their heads around.
CNN: Now to a dire warning about climate
change. According to a new report,
experts say that we have until 2030 to avoid
catastrophe. It also says if unprecedented
changes are not made, and made soon, there
will be irreversible damage to the planet.
Al Jazeera: One of the world’s coldest
regions is witnessing a record number of
wildfires. The heatwave has
lit a match to the arctic.
CNN: We’ve had, of course, more record floods,
we have more significant droughts,
we have all these events.
University of Michigan: People start to recognize
that this isn't some hypothetical future. This
is our present reality, and it's going to
cost us money, and it is costing us money.
SIERRA:
Climate change is the most important issue of our
lives. But time and again it seems to take a back
seat to more immediate problems. The evidence is
clear - wildfires, drought, heatwaves, extreme
weather and flooding have moved from scientific
models to daily headlines. And yet there are
still so many powerful interests that want to
deny the problem, or delay dealing with it.
But in the face of reluctance, one surefire way
to get someone’s attention, is to take aim at
their wallet. Money talks, and that remains true
even when it comes to saving the planet. So we
were curious, how do markets, investments, and
climate change intersect? I’m Gabrielle Sierra,
and this is Why It Matters. Today, the economic
dilemma of climate change and whether or not
financial markets can make a difference.
SIERRA:
So do you think you can give us some of the big
climate updates for the last year because 2020 has
been a bit of a rough one. And I think that a lot
of people have been distracted from the long term.
MACKENZIE: 2020 has been talked about in the
last few years, by a lot of climate experts as
a really important year. It's the point at which
we would expect to start seeing emissions decline.
My name is Kate Mackenzie. I write a column for
Bloomberg Green. I also advise organizations
that are working towards achieving the Paris
Agreement goals in all kinds of capacities.
So we sometimes call that “bending the curve”,
because our annual emissions have been increasing
most years for obviously, you know, many, many
decades now. And that’s the first thing that
needs to change is that annual growth rate
needs to really end and start reversing at a
fairly steep rate. Because there's obviously a lot
less air travel and certain other kinds of transit
in particular and activity, obviously, emissions
are down this year. It's not really clear whether
that's going to be permanent and it's not clear
at what point you know, that might rebound. And,
you know, we don't want a lot of these particular
changes to be permanent because they're so
harmful. We need to cut those emissions in other
ways. Are we on the right track? There's a lot
of encouraging signs. But there's also a lot
of causes for concern. The overall emissions
trajectory, if you kind of plot it out on a chart,
it's still not on a pathway that we should be on.
There's also, I guess, questions about the
international process and the extent to which
countries are meeting their commitments under the
Paris agreement to target cutting their emissions
and whether they're actually doing that quickly
enough and keeping up with the schedule. The
big UN Climate meeting that usually takes place
at the end of the year is postponed this year,
until late next year. But that process is still
continuing in the background where countries are
still being asked to look at their emissions
plans, look at their long term plans and talk
about how they're actually planning to cut
their emissions to get to net zero by 2050.
SIERRA: Alright, so it sounds like we
still have a lot of work to do. Can't,
shouldn't rely on a pandemic to get us to
do the right thing for the environment.
MACKENZIE: Yeah, definitely not.
SIERRA: Even before we were grappling
with a public health crisis, the United
States was moving away from important
climate initiatives. At the end of 2019,
the Trump administration formally announced that
it would withdraw the US from the Paris Agreement,
abandoning nearly 200 countries that had
pledged to reduce greenhouse gas emissions.
Many experts feel that this agreement is the
world’s last and best shot at keeping the globe
from reaching the temperature of no return - a
2-degree celsius increase from pre-industrial
levels. A big part of the administration’s
rationale for leaving the agreement was that
it presented a threat to the U.S. economy -
this argument that has struck many economists
and climate scientists as misguided, given the
dire economic threats of climate change itself.
MACKENZIE: So there's two main ways to think
about climate change in financial markets.
If you think about things that you own or things
that can be bought and sold on financial markets,
these can be affected in two main ways by climate
change. One is, as the world moves away from what
we call a carbon intensive economy, companies and
assets that have assumed that that won't happen
will lose value. The best example, I suppose,
would be something like coal fired power stations.
SIERRA: Investing your money in a coal company
is a prediction. By investing, you’re saying,
“I believe that this coal company will
be more valuable in the future than it
is now.” If your prediction is wrong, and
climate regulations and renewable energy
sources eliminate the demand for coal, the
company loses value, and you lose money.
MACKENZIE: At the moment, a large proportion
of the world's coal fired power stations are
no longer profitable. This is largely because
renewable electricity has become so much cheaper
to generate. So that, you can actually build
new renewable energy resources for cheaper
than running existing coal fired power plants in a
lot of places now. As that's happened, obviously,
if you're a company that runs those power plants,
or owns the mines that supply those power plants,
investors are not very keen on your shares
anymore or on investing in your bonds,
because you're not gonna be able to pay them back.
So that's a really present example. You can see
there are similar things starting to happen in
the oil industry, there have been growing signs
that oil is not going to have this infinitely,
endlessly growing market that has often been
assumed in the past. So that's just one side
of it. And then the other side is what is often
called “physical risk.” Which is things getting
damaged businesses, buildings, crops, people's
ability to work, all of these things being
affected by the impacts of climate change itself.
And that's another way that you can see
financial losses accrue from climate change.
SIERRA: Physical risk is not theoretical, it’s
already causing serious damage to corporations and
economies. A University of Maryland study found
that disruptions to global supply chains from
weather doubled in 2017. Just this year, Pacific
Gas and Electric, California’s largest utility,
declared bankruptcy due to billions in liabilities
from wildfires. Google is making contingency plans
to cool its data centers as temperatures
rise. The Climate Disclosure Project,
estimates roughly $1 trillion in total
business costs in the coming decades.
SIERRA: Interesting. So it seems like
the two main things are 1.) it will
affect your product because people
won’t want to buy it or invest in it,
right? If it's a product that's no
longer, environmentally friendly,
or even sustainable. And the other way is
that your building could get destroyed,
your plant could get destroyed. So climate
change affects you on those two basic levels.
MACKENZIE: Yeah, that's it exactly. The
other thing about financial markets is
that they're forward-looking by nature. So once
enough participants in a market can see
these changes emerging or approaching,
that starts to be what we would call “priced
in.” So people start changing their idea of
the value of an asset because they can see in
the future that this loss is going to happen.
SIERRA: As these problems become more clear,
some investors are starting to get better at
predicting climate risk, and are demanding
that the companies they invest in do the
same. One example is Norway’s trillion-dollar
sovereign wealth fund, which has pledged to
use its influence to force companies to behave
more responsibly. But the trend had its most
visible moment earlier this year, following a
letter written by BlackRock CEO, Larry Fink.
KILLIK: Climate change is
very much back on the agenda,
following the publishing of a letter from
BlackRock’s chief executive, Larry Fink.
CNBC: 0:04-0:13 Fink’s annual letter is out. The
world’s largest asset manager now announcing the
firm will make investment decisions with
environmental sustainability at its core.
RT America: Asset manager BlackRock handles
over $7 trillion in direct management,
and another $20 trillion through
their proprietary software.
MACKENZIE: So BlackRock invests money on behalf
of other people, they manage those investments
on behalf of largely things like pension funds,
so, you know, where you and I would hopefully be
having some savings for our retirement, that
fund might then you know, pass that money
to BlackRock to decide how to allocate it into
different companies and different asset classes.
BlackRock is the biggest company that offers this
kind of service of asset management in the world.
They’re therefore a very powerful entity, you
know, they own a little chunk of almost every
company in the world. So when they write to the
CEOs of those companies or the directors and CEOs,
it's often seen as a, you know, an important
signal, even though it's just a letter.
So, he wrote to company directors, basically
saying that they would be expecting more
disclosure from the companies. So disclosure is
a huge area of interest both for investors and
companies when they talk about climate change
and financial climate risk. The idea is that
if the company can identify and then disclose
what climate risks it thinks it's exposed to,
then investors can make their decision about
whether they think the company is well set up for
the future or not. Larry Fink also reiterated in
this letter, a threat that had been made a couple
of years earlier, which is that they would vote
against the reappointment of company directors
if they feel that the company or that those
directors are not adequately disclosing their
climate risk or a strategy to address climate
change. There's quite a lot in the Larry Fink
letter. He makes it clear that this is about
profitability, this is about returns. So, as is
often the case where you have climate change being
discussed in the financial world, he's emphasizing
that it's not necessarily a political or a moral
agenda. It's just a traditional finance agenda,
traditional focus on investment returns and
investment risks. And it's just looking at
these emerging and new influences on those returns
and risks, which is in this case climate change.
SIERRA: So just a good business decision.
MACKENZIE: Exactly. And that's
very often how it's portrayed
and how it’s framed and how it is
understood in the financial world.
GREENSTONE: So I think Larry Fink's
letter was terrific, and in many respects,
is emblematic of some recent activity from
the corporate sector. My name is Michael
Greenstone and I'm a professor of economics
at the University of Chicago and I direct
the Energy Policy Institute as well as the Becker
Friedman Institute, both at the university here.
SIERRA: In addition, Dr. Greenstone served as
the chief economist of the Council of Economic
Advisors under the Obama administration.
Later, he started a non profit called
“Carbon Vault” that allows individuals and
businesses to offset their carbon footprints.
GREENSTONE: But what its emblematic of is a
recognition that there has not been appropriate
policies in response to the climate risk. And
so, you've seen individuals and you've seen
corporations start to try and take a leadership
role. There's limits to what any individual
corporation can accomplish, but you started to see
that. I see BlackRock’s letter as kind of a shot
across the bow in terms of raising consciousness
and activating shareholder activism. And that's
important. It's certainly not the same thing as
forceful policy. There have also been some other
important examples. I think Microsoft and Apple
have been absolute leaders in terms of taking on
reductions in their own emissions, in very, very
thoughtful and careful ways, it's not an easy
thing to do. For reasons we could unpack for many
more hours than any reasonable listener would be
interested in. But they stand out as real leaders.
I think it's also true that in that wave of
interest, there have been a lot of others who have
been closer to greenwashing. And by that I mean
saying something publicly, but the actions not
having been very consequential and that can show
up in buying carbon offsets that are unverifiable,
very inexpensive, or, you know, incentivizing aims
to purchase renewable electricity. That can be
done in a way that is really additive. But most
of the time, it's done by paying very small
amounts to wind generation farms in Texas and
Oklahoma that would have been operating anyway.
So it looks good, but has very little impact.
SIERRA: What does it mean to assess climate
risk? How do you measure something like that?
MACKENZIE: That's such a complicated question.
SIERRA: Break it down.
MACKENZIE: And so many people are working on
this very question in so many different ways.
So you can look at it in a fairly straightforward
way. In the first type of climate risk, which is
often called ‘transition risk’ so it’s about that
transition away from emissions, where you might
have you know, renewables replacing coal. That is
often initially assessed by looking at a company
or another kind of issuing entity, looking at how
much does their business model rely on producing
things or selling things that are very high
emissions, and how easy is it, and how willing
is that company to change? There would be very few
financial services companies that don't at least
avail themselves to that type of analysis. It gets
a lot more complicated when you're talking about
companies that maybe aren't producing fossil fuels
themselves and maybe aren't burning it themselves,
but they're dependent on other industries
that do use emissions or that do generate
greenhouse gas emissions. So if you're
looking at, say, a car manufacturer,
they're only emitting greenhouse gases in their
production of the cars. But then you'd be looking
at their strategy. Are they moving towards low
emissions vehicles and electric vehicles? How
much of their business is dedicated to this
currently? Are they still expecting to be
selling gas guzzling SUVs, which tend to be, you
know, fairly profitable at the moment? Are they
banking on that being a big part of their business
model for years to come? And that's where it gets
into a little bit more of the art of looking
at their strategy and their long term planning.
SIERRA: Could you walk me through how
climate change might affect businesses
that aren't so clearly connected to it? You know,
I'm thinking more about companies like Coke
or Nike or a pharmaceutical company. I mean,
is this something that you think will
affect all businesses in one way or another?
MACKENZIE: Yeah, it's interesting, actually,
those sorts of companies, companies in those
consumer-facing industries have tended to be more
proactive in looking at their role in reducing
emissions than a lot of other industries. And in
fact, it's often wildly financially advantageous,
if you switch to renewable energy.
And you can also tell your consumers,
you know, you can also tell people about
how great and green you are as a company.
For those companies, it's also a question of,
to what extent things like the availability
of water might be impacted by climate change,
transport, supply chain systems that they rely
on. So things like water availability are
something that a lot of companies have been
looking at for years now. Extreme heat,
storms and cyclones, things like that.
SIERRA: So basically, it's just them
analyzing whether or not they will be
able to make their products in the same way
in 10 or 20 years as the effects pile up.
MACKENZIE: Exactly. And get them to
people that they sell them to ultimately.
SIERRA: So if you would play my
financial advisor for a second,
because I don't have one. Are the odds good
that as climate risk becomes more clear that
Wall Street could become like an ally in the
fight for climate action? Is that a good bet?
MACKENZIE: It’s interesting because, you know,
in a sense because some investment managers,
particularly the ones that are looking after
people's pensions, they are obliged to think about
the long term. Pension funds are actually legally
obliged in many parts of the world to think about
the long term interests of the members of their
fund. So I think it's no coincidence that those
sorts of pension funds have been at the forefront
of thinking about climate change in the financial
world. Investment banks tend to do quite a few
other activities that tend to be more short term
in focus, you know, M&A deals, IPOs and so on.
So I think investment banks are probably coming
to this topic a bit later than some of their
financial peers that are closer to the pension
fund sector. There are some people who will say,
‘Well, if climate change is a financial risk,
perhaps, the markets and financial self
interest can, can solve it’. If we had a
lot more time to make these changes, I guess
I would be more sympathetic to that argument.
SIERRA: So you know when you have a theory,
and then it doesn’t exactly pan out? That seems
to be the case here with whether financial
markets can become climate allies on their
own. As promising as the BlackRock letter and
other trends appear - there’s still too much
money to be made on fossil fuels and short term
investments that ignore our planet’s future. And
by the time physical risks hurt enough bottom
lines to force a change, it may be too late.
We’re going to take a short break, but when we get
back - what will it really take to change markets?
SIERRA: Do you think that regulation will be
necessary before broad corporate change occurs?
MACKENZIE: Yeah, I absolutely think it is, and
it will be really essential. Unfortunately, the
thing about each individual business or bank, or
investor that we look at, they're all sitting on
top of a very big system that has a lot of rules
and conventions that did not evolve with climate
change in mind. So, one very simple problem that
is often discussed in this world is what's called
‘time horizons’. So investors want to look at
the report every three months or six months or
a year of how their investments are performing.
And they want to see that their investments are
doing well. They're not necessarily thinking about
the longer term. And a lot of the financial system
as it currently works, a lot of things like
accounting rules, financial reporting rules,
all of these rules evolved, really, without
regard to long term impacts, but also without
regard to the sort of the physical world that we
exist in, in a sense. So, this is what economists
call ‘externalities’. If you're a company that can
pollute, without bearing any of the cost of that
pollution, then you're almost obliged to do it,
if that improves your profits, then you're kind
of almost expected to do it and, and obliged to do
it, even if it has a really negative effect for,
the rest of society. It's kind of challenging
to think about but a lot of that needs to start
shifting, in order for us as humans, to you
know, have a kind of stable and safe world
that we would like to be able to enjoy and we'd
like our kids and grandkids to be able to enjoy.
SIERRA: Climate change is undeniable, but not all
of its effects are not immediate. Transitioning
your business model to become carbon neutral
is expensive, and you don’t know when you’ll
make the money back. Shareholders don’t like
losses. Many economists think the only answer
is regulation. Governments can pass laws that make
it expensive to produce carbon. Once you do that,
the math changes. And markets have a new set of
problems to solve. Transitioning your company
to become carbon neutral is no longer a long-term
adaptation, but an immediate business necessity.
SIERRA: So what do you see as the most effective
types of regulations when it comes to emissions?
GREENSTONE: You know, the economics of it,
the blackboard economics are kind of boring.
It's very simple. You just put a price or tax on
the thing that you don't like. And in that case,
it's co2. And then you let the market sort
out as to where the cheapest reductions are
going to come from. And you know, there are
very successful markets on that right now.
The European Union has a very successful cap
and trade program for co2. There's 9 or 10,
maybe it's now 10 or 11 states along the east
coast that are in the regional greenhouse gas
emissions cap and trade. And California has
one. And so those have been very successful.
SIERRA: For those who need it, here’s what
you need to know about carbon regulations.
The two big options are carbon taxes
and what’s known as “cap and trade”.
A carbon tax is a tax placed on the amount
of greenhouse gases produced by a company.
The more carbon produced, the more the company
has to pay the government. This establishes a
direct cost for releasing emissions into the air.
With cap and trade, the government defines the
maximum amount of carbon that can be produced by
companies in a given state, region, or country.
Within this system, companies that produce
more carbon emissions than their cap allows
can buy the right to do so from companies that
produce less. The goal is to allow the market to
set the price of carbon, which in turn can drive
investment and innovation towards green solutions.
The pros and cons of each are hotly
debated, but most agree that a well
designed set of policies are the only sure way
to reduce overall greenhouse gas emissions.
As advocates sought to promote these ideas,
they came up with another term worth
knowing - the “social cost of carbon”.
GREENSTONE: I like to call it the most important
number you've never heard of. So the social cost
of carbon is really pretty simple, once
you cut through all the words. If I put
a ton of co2 in the atmosphere today, what are
the damages it's going to cost to the economy,
as long as that ton of co2 in the atmosphere?
And I, under the President's direction, Cass
Sunstein and I had the idea that the United States
government should have a social cost of carbon.
And in 2009 and 2010, we led a process and set
it, and if you were to follow through that number
is about $51 a ton. And so, a way to say that in
English is that every ton of co2, carbon dioxide,
that we abate produces $51 of global benefits. So
those benefits are reductions in climate damages.
You know, markets are constructions
of people's beliefs and government.
And the governments really set the rules of the
road and it's hard to point to what markets would
systematically have to react to if there isn't
government policy. And, you know, just returning
to our conversation about BlackRock and Microsoft,
I think their moves are very important. They raise
awareness and they have some impact on carbon
emissions. But realistically, it's all pretty
small relative to the government or governments
around the world, setting a forceful climate
policy and then markets would have something
real and immediate to react to and they would.
You would see a revaluation of companies based
on their usage and production of fossil fuels.
SIERRA: And that’s good news. With the right
policies and incentives, markets could unleash
their power to help slow climate change,
rather than fueling its acceleration. But
there’s an important caveat to how far the
policies of highly developed nations can go.
GREENSTONE: I think it's very natural, as we
sit here in the United States to be focused on
US policy and what US corporations are doing,
but I have a concern that sometimes we become
excessively focused on that. And that concern
is grounded in the fact that climate change,
really it is global climate change. And, if
one looks at the projections for the United
States share of emissions going forward,I think
it's about 15% for the rest of the century. So,
unless the rest of the world finds it advantageous
to engage in reducing emissions, it's going to be
hard to make a lot of progress. And I think what
can help is if we don't think of it as the climate
change crisis, but rather we think of it as the
global energy challenge. And in particular, I see
the global energy challenge as this challenge that
all societies have to confront in their own way.
And I think there's three main goals that underpin
this challenge. The first is how do you make sure
that your society has access to inexpensive and
reliable sources of energy, that power economic
growth and allow people to improve their living
standards and lead much more comfortable lives and
they are currently.The second is, how do you do
that without suffering the health effects of air
pollution? And the reason they're interlinked is
because the very fossil fuels that often provide
the least expensive sources of energy, also often
involved the release of particulate matter. And
that causes all kinds of health problems, as we're
seeing in India and China. And we saw previously,
you know, several decades ago in the United
States. And then the third leg of the stool,
I think is that the same fossil fuels that are
inexpensive and it can lead to very pernicious
air pollution also, are increasing the odds of
disruptive climate change. And what societies,
this is the United States, this is India, this is
China, this is countries in Sub Saharan Africa,
it's Bangladesh, Pakistan, all have to figure out
is a way to balance and navigate between those
three goals. And if the climate, if the global
energy challenge looks like it's going to involve
massively more expensive energy, it's going
to be very difficult to bring people in other
countries along and I think one example that's
very instructive. I do a lot of work in the state
of Bihar. In India, their per capita, electric
annual per capita electricity consumes about 200
kilowatt hours per year. In the United States,
it's 13,000. So trying to get people in Bihar,
focused on climate risk, when they're at
about 200 kilowatt hours per year, is very,
very challenging. And so all of that points
to it's not enough for the United States to
find a way to reduce carbon emissions. But
it's critical for the United States and the
world to identify innovations that, kind of,
can soften some of the trade offs associated
with that global energy challenge and a lot of
that's going to turn on innovation and reducing
the costs of clean energy and/or reducing
the costs of carbon removal technologies.
SIERRA: Two dinosaurs looking up at a meteor,
and one says “Oh no, the economy.” We get it.
Once the world ends, there’s no more economy to
worry about. But, that doesn't mean that it’s not
worth talking about climate change in economic
terms. Doing so gives us a common language for
addressing the facts and clarifies the idea that
nobody is going to turn a profit unless we get
our act together. Money talks. And while climate
change can only be mitigated by global solutions,
the richest country on earth does still have the
world’s ear. If the US can make the right changes
at home, and regain its global leadership,
it could do some very loud talking indeed.
SIERRA: Do you think that a climate skeptic
might be more convinced of the problem when
banks and insurance companies and not just
climate scientists are telling them ‘No,
we can't insure that house’, ‘No, you
can't have a loan to build on the coast,
because from our analysis, those places
won't exist in 20 years’? I mean,
do you think that that will and does
bring new people into the conversation?
GREENSTONE: There is little more powerful than
price signals reverberating through the economy.
What do I mean by ‘price signals’? Exactly what
you said. ‘Hey, I'd like to get insurance on my
house on the New Jersey coast’ and the insurance
companies’ rates have just gone up by five times’,
that's going to get people's attention. And so to
the degree that there are physical impacts that
start to get priced, that is gonna matter a lot.
And to the degree that there's policy that starts
to get priced into assets, that's going to matter
a lot. And I think there's no amount of asking
for people's charity that is comparable to people
facing very clear and very strong price signals.
SIERRA:
Want to learn more about the role of
markets and the economy in climate
change? Head to CFR.org/WhyItMatters
for the show notes from this episode.
Interested in saying ‘hey’ to
the Why It Matters team? You can
always reach out on email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
If you are a fan, subscribe to the
show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio. And
if you like what you hear, leave us a review!
And hey, if you’ve got the
time to get even more specific,
we’re running a survey over
at cfr.org/podcast-survey.
Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by
Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is
Markus Zakaria and our summer intern is
Wynne Dieffenbach. Robert McMahon is
our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey
is our Chief Digital Officer. Kayla Ermanni
provided us with extra help on this episode.
Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special
thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra, signing off see you soon!